hi guys today I am finally going to talk
to you about my university experience
I'm gonna share with you the truth the
highs the lows why I went what I got out
of it what I would do differently and
any advice I think would be great
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
finally under the stress no you're
recording me here
[Music]
now first of all who the hell am i why
should you even listen to me well I have
recently just graduated University for
computer games arts and the third ear
game perfection actually kind of blew up
online for a little bit which was great
and I have managed to find myself a
trainee game design job from it that I
will be starting in the new year so hey
happy but how can you get to where you
want to be and is university the right
path for you maybe my story can help you
cuz I'm gonna share my top 10 tips that
I did or didn't do some of them I didn't
do and I wish I did do so you can learn
from from the things that I didn't do
okay so my first tip about University
and making the most out of it is don't
go basically you don't have to go to
university straight away I didn't go to
university straight away and I will say
to everybody it is probably one of the
best decisions I have ever made now of
course this sounds kind of like
counteractive because why wouldn't you
just want to get a head start and go to
uni straight away and then you've got
your degree under your belt and you can
just go out into the world and get a job
easy peasy right no you need more than
just a piece of paper to get a job
unfortunately you need life skills and
kind of communication and and you need
to know people you need to like get out
there get out of your comfort zone and
unfortunately even though University
does do some stuff to help you get out
of that comfort zone it also is still
wrapped up in the education bubble so
having some life experience fast really
really helps and not only just helps you
in a career sense but also helps you get
to know yourself and what you might want
to get out of university which is vital
the main reason why I didn't go
to university was that I didn't know
what I wanted to do I adored film but I
also really really loved game
development so I just didn't know what
path to take and then my college at the
time said well maybe you don't go to uni
and you just do an apprenticeship in
London instead so I was like yeah that
sounds sounds good to me so essentially
I moved to London I worked in a
advertising company being a web
developer just like learning how to code
and stuff and it just taught me so much
that university could not teach me just
can not teach you because I had to move
out of my house out of my hometown to a
whole new city so you had to learn about
like how to find houses like you know
admin fees and deposits and paying rent
on time you have to learn all of that
let alone you know just trying to cook
for yourself and buy food and things all
things and then I worked for a year
after that before realizing my true
passion is game development or creating
interactive storytelling mediums this is
not a life story why am i rambling
basically just find yourself before you
go to university find yourself and what
you want to do and then you can make the
most out of being at university if you
decide that is where would be best for
you to go if you're not too sure carry
on listen to this so number two is know
why you're going to university before
you go to university also don't worry
about your age age was a big deal to me
don't know why because I thought I was
gonna be so much older than everyone
else because I take in these couple
years out but actually everyone is
various ages anyway even if you're a few
years older a few years younger nobody
is going to care at the end of the day
you're just all working together to try
and get your deadlines done
it's work as a team to like be friendly
and you're all there because you share a
passion in
whatever you're studying which is really
freaking lovely so anyway yeah don't
worry about the age thing totally fine
know why you're going don't importance a
lot of people I feel go to university
because they think it's the only option
or because it's what like people tell
them to do or just what society deems
you should do right but times change in
you don't actually need a degree to do
everything you might need it for some
things I went and did a creative course
computer games art I mean most of that
is to do with portfolios and things like
that so you don't necessarily need to go
to university but you need to know if
you are going to go why are you going
are you going because you realize that
you need more time to learn the skills
that you want to learn if you're working
a nine-to-five job five days a week you
don't have much time or is it just the
fact that you don't have access to
equipment that you know University is
going to give you that access well is it
because and this might sound weird but
this was one of my reasons why I went to
university you want to make friends
because I'd spent so long doing my
apprenticeship and grinding my way
through London I kind of haven't really
made any friends around my age or or
anything so I just wanted to kind of get
back into that friendship environment of
being in the university which it's a
perfectly valid reason as well because
at the end of the day it's your life
and if you want to go for a reason that
might seem silly to others but it means
a lot to you you know what you want at
the end of the day trust yourself so if
you have thought about why you might
want to go to university and you've
decided it is a good idea for you to go
save some money before you get there
because unfortunately nowadays your
student loans won't cover much a lot of
my friends and in my experience it
didn't even cover rent say it depends on
where you're going to university some
universities are in places where the
accommodation and things are just
slightly higher probably have to get
yourself a job but hopefully if you have
pre-planned this it will all work out
for you ah number four
move move move move do
kind of university in your hometown
unless you've decided that the course
it's like amazing and there's no course
like it elsewhere or you her actually
moved before and you've already had that
experience of being completely out of
your comfort bubble because like I say
there's so much that you get from like
moving out of your hometown and moving
away from your family and learning to do
everything independently on your own to
feed yourself to pay your rent
it's life lessons that everybody needs
to learn and the earliest you learn the
better will be for you in the long run
naturally University is a really nice
safe space for this it was kind of a
step back for me because being thrust
into London I was like what the hell and
then to figure out everything on my own
and that was terrifying
and then when I got to university a lot
of people are in the same boat but a lot
of people were in that boat together so
the people who went to sure like how to
cook a meal for themselves would sit
down and cook together and figure it out
together and people that weren't too
sure about like how deposits worked or
or how to find a new house in their
second year they could do that together
so yeah it was just a lot easier and a
lot nicer number five and this might
sound like I'm doing number ten no
number five in my fund a little bit with
this one but just bear with me here so
right now I've been doing some associate
lecturing since I have graduated and
I've been speaking to first-year
students and things like that that I've
been helping teach and I see this just
in a lot of people I saw it when I was
in university it's the people perhaps
have things about their university
course that they don't so much like oh
they think perhaps could be run better
or they have suggestions or things like
that about it but they don't want to be
a nuisance they they don't want to talk
to the course leader or anything that
because they just don't want to be a
pain or they just feel like they don't
have a right to to kind of say these
things and you know I'm not saying that
you should go in and be all angry and
if you had an idea in your head like
what you're going to learn in the way
that was going to be set out and things
like that and then you get there and you
realize it's not quite what you imagined
you're within your rights to speak up
about that Laurie even change course if
you really want to I actually did when I
did computer games up instead which I'm
so glad because it turns out that it's
definitely where my passion lies but I
wouldn't have made that decision if it
weren't for my parents actually telling
me you've paid nine thousand pound a
year for this course and if you feel
this is not what you want oh you're not
gonna get out of it what you need to get
out of it you need to do something about
that up to you it's your money
um so you need to you need to sort it
out so I did luckily and I switched
courses in my second month of university
but honestly the same goes for you
you're in University even if you're in
like second or third year it's not too
late if you think that there's changes
that could be made or you know there's
something that you want to learn that
you were under the assumption you were
going to learn and you're not learning
it talks to the course leaders I did
that and they told me exactly what was
going to happen they basically said no
this course is not gonna give you what
you need but this course might and then
I jumped over it's all great doesn't
have to be awkward doesn't have to be
confrontational it can just be a
discussion between two adults because
that's what you are at uni if you're 18
35:22
doesn't matter you're an adult and you
paid for this so I think I think it's
like it's good to realize that like it's
not a school anymore you know it's not
teach here in the student it's two
adults you're not old scary thought no
I'm a rambling and I am rambling you're
paying that nine thousand pounds we've
just we've just spoken about that
horrendous I know but
you paint this in some really strange
and I'm sorry to say this but you're not
just paying for knowledge and you can't
expect your lecturers just sit down hold
your hand and tell you how to do if them
because what are the major things that
you're paying for that you don't even
really notice until you're out of
university it's time so I know you're
gonna be like I don't get that much
spare time but you do but you do though
I know a lot of it it's been on your
course and everything else but what
you're doing for your course hopefully
is what you love and it's what you're
passionate about and hopefully that you
would choose to be doing every single
day it might be slightly not exactly
because you're working to a brief and to
your University standard and like
whatever but ultimately you're probably
not gonna get this chance again
because then you'll have to get a job
afterwards and unless you get your dream
job straight after University which is
not gonna stay impossible but it's
unlikely you're not gonna get this much
time to just be working on something
that you love so just bear that in mind
and really use that time wisely um this
is me being so real here about
university but you will get annoyed I'd
like the lecturers and stuff like that
just thinking like they're not being
able to teach you enough and like not
all of them and perfect but that's okay
because it's what you make of it and you
might think your university is the only
one that is like this or has like
lecturers like that but unfortunately it
will be like that everywhere you can
look around I mean definitely look
around before you even go to university
anyway use that time and use the people
and just go out and do fun stuff like
explore and make short films just for
you and just take photos just for a for
you and your friends instagrams like I
don't know just play around have fun oh
and not leave nicely onto number seven
but just make bean and join societies so
this is one thing that I wish I did more
of I didn't join a society
until year three and abortion yeah three
yeah three it's so hectic so sorry we do
anyone here than third year
that's your you are under a lot of
stress right now but it's okay you'll
get through it I trust you I believe in
you and you can do that dissertation
you've got this I wish I joined a
society earlier on I joined music
Society in third year and it was like
super fun but a lot of the time
especially near in the end I just
couldn't even go anymore because it was
just too much there was too much stuff
but this is the time for you to branch
out and try every single hobby that you
have ever had be that like music or
dancing or football or you know just
like absolutely anything there's
probably a society for it and it does
not forget start one and then you
building up extra skill of it along
inside your course also making friends
just so good because especially in the
arts courses like the one I did having a
lot of friends with different skills
helps you a lot I was known as my
friends courses main actress because I
was in pretty much my brother for this
act you buy it
that's so like camera
and they help me with the game so they
were always play testing my game they
were giving me inputs and if I needed
them to help me with photography or
anything like that they were more than
up for it so just make friends help each
other and have fun so number eight ties
in with number six actually as I said
you're paying for time as well as
knowledge it's really helpful to always
keep thinking beyond your final grade
like what is gonna happen after
University and how can you use this time
now to really make that happen so I was
constantly worried about this and this
is me as a press and I guess I'm just
boring about the future like constantly
but it really helped me because I was
able to document like everything that I
was doing at University I made like a
tutorial video in first year which
probably isn't that great but it showed
that I knew how to do 3d modeling all
the basics at least I did art livestream
I did game dev vlogs I sat down with my
team and made videos about how we were
going to go from conceptualizing a game
to actually making a game and then I did
game dev live streams and all of this is
now saved on my youtube channel and she
used to show potential employers that
hey I made a game but I didn't just make
a game I also was a game designer and I
managed a team this is what how we
learnt and this is how I did things and
I have proof of all of that you don't
have to make a youtube channel you can
just keep a log of it like make a blog
or something like that make sure that
you're keeping everything in the same
place because you don't want to lose it
after University everything that you're
doing now especially in an arts course
needs to be kept so that you can have a
portfolio but when you leave University
and also use that time
and go to events if your university
offers free tickets to go to events
which mine did quite often and a lot of
people just didn't go because they were
busy with deadlines and things like that
which I totally understand but it's at
these events that you meet your next
potential employers or your potential
co-workers like all you get influence
that's not a word or you get inspiration
from I guess in a way it's a shame but
it's really true it is it is about who
you know and if you can start building
up that reputation now while you're
learning that's just gonna be such a
great help and internships this is gonna
help you so much on the money front of
things as well if you manage to get
yourself a paid internship some
universities will ask you to do this
yourself anyway or help you for this
others won't and I think even if they
don't which mine didn't you should just
look for one yourself it's just gonna be
so beneficial especially if you haven't
worked before going to university
because then you can get out of uni and
say I have this degree but I've also got
this experience of working within the
industry already I know it's difficult
and it seems at the time like you can
only get an internship after uni if you
haven't managed to get one before you
finish University it's not the end of
the world but I would say please at
least try to get one like during uni or
during the summer at least I was so so
lucky and I got offered one in my second
year summer so just before third year
and it wasn't even in what I wanted to
be doing when I got out of university
but I knew that any experience is gonna
be amazing
it's gonna help you so much more than
not having one it's also so take it take
it okay number nine we're nearly there
goes number nine I know I've just been
rabble rabble rabble your grade your
grade grade grade your grade you're
gonna you're gonna freak out about your
grade I know I did I won a first one of
the first one first guess what I got
[Music]
two or three percents away from a fast
okay this is my big reveal
[Music]
and I was like 2% away from my first but
at the end of the day just because
you've got a first really doesn't mean
that you're going to get a job straight
away
in fact some really successful people
that have spoken to barely scraped it
with a - one or two - especially in
creative courses a lot of it is
subjective personally so my game
perfection I'm so freakin happy with but
the amount of people that gave me so
much positive feedback on it but I'm not
gonna lie my main lecturer he wasn't
that keen on it and then I did get
pressed my dissertation I wish I'm very
happy that cuz I actually really love
writing so yeah that bumps it up but I
didn't ultimately get it first but
that's okay because then I was like you
know what screw it and I took his
feedback from the final grade into
account I made some changes and then I
put it onto each i/o and then BOOM yay
so honestly if you don't get at first
it's not the end of the world it's
really not the end of the world just
make sure you get your degree and make
sure you're ticking the boxes but
especially in creative courses if you
feel like it's something that you're
truly passionate about and you know that
you need to do something that's probably
a reason why you feel that way you know
what I mean if you're creative type you
know you get those feelings you like
done and just because you don't reach
that fast does not mean that you're not
good enough it does not mean that you're
not gonna get a job does not mean that
you should give up number 10 and we've
made it we've made its number 10 you've
made it through my round well thank you
so much already appreciate you enjoy it
enjoy University it's it really is a
once-in-a-lifetime opportunity and I am
so thankful to everyone who gave me the
advice to go when I wasn't sure whether
I should go or not everyone said to me
you're never going to experience
anything
like University and I was kinda like oh
yeah you learn about the pies and
they're drinking cuz I'm not a massive
party girl
but it's not just that like honestly you
live with people who become your second
family you're all in the same boat
together whether you have come from a
different country whether you are
slightly older whether you have never
left your hometown before you're all
under immense like stress trying to get
a good grade trying to meet your
deadlines but also trying to make new
friends and trying to understand a whole
new part of your life and trying to come
to terms with who you are as a person
who you want to be as a person
after University and forming a bond
based on those premises is it's truly
special and it's something that you
won't ever forget and hopefully your
stay friends with those people for a
very long time I know I am going to try
my very hardest to stay in contact with
everyone that I live with and that I
formed that bond with and also what I
will say to you is keep that University
mentality of striving and and pushing
yourself and getting excited and
reaching deadlines and maybe even giving
yourself deadlines I've done that ever
since I've left University and it's
helped me a lot it's helped me to find a
job it's also helped me to finalize
things that I perhaps started in
University so I went to a creative uni
and I started creative projects with my
friends or my own just because we wanted
to and I took it upon myself to carry
those projects on even though I was no
longer with those friends that I spoke
about the project's - originally such as
my EP which is coming and I'm very
excited and also giving myself a
deadline to find a job which I actually
went beyond
oops but I found one else it's okay
really helped me to stay grounded and to
feel positive about the future because
it's very daunting once you leave
University so do keep that mentality of
of pushing yourself of working hard of
working towards something and of
thinking about life in the future so
anyway those were my top ten tips and
probably a few more just kind of like
sprinkled in there of how to get the
very most out of university if you
decide to go because like I said at the
very beginning it's not the only path to
take but there are many many reasons to
go to university if you feel it's right
for you and if you take the time to use
the time wisely if you feel like I've
missed out on anything that you learn
through your time at university or that
you're learning in uni right now
then do write them in the comments below
and I wish you the best of luck oh no
ma'am and if you want more advice on
anything let me know in the comments
below this video a like okay
[Music]